let's take a walk
[Laughter]
anything goes wrong you bust in there
act like you have lap that lie
you cannot speak english
okay just really give it a good
so
that's
one i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry it was so long
i'm sorry
our tops
susan
news
[Laughter]
susan
i'm bruce nolan
and that's the way the cookie crumbles
oh you eating that sorry
new
news
news
news
news
news
susan
i can't marry you why would you know
nothing what do you mean no was it you
no i've just been doing a lot of
thinking and i just don't think
you like that [ __ ]
hmm
you [ __ ] my beard is it good do
you think this is funny huh
i don't like it in the ass either
hey man what you doing hey man relax i'm
just getting some nuts
who are you well i'll be whoever you
want me to be but you can call me genie
how does somebody as big as you fit into
this tiny lamp don't worry i'm used to
squeezing myself into titles
can you help us we're in danger
holland is the netherlands
then who are the dutch
you know i can't stand
you know
i love you
santa as close as it's gonna get dave
i love you
[Music]
i'm not gonna do it come on man 400 he's
trying to kiss me for real [ __ ] four
hundred dollars he's trying to kiss me
for real y'all
[Applause]
it's the creator screwed up
no laughing
[Music]
if i was a boxer i would
bounce those things like sugar ray
leonard i'm sure
no there's not any cream in here i swear
i
swear what no there's not
come on there's no cream in here
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're crazy i love you
god damn it hey pal let me finish
[Music]
yes yes
oh damn
come away with me don't be afraid with a
tongue like that we can make millions
ugh
let me see
no no like this
oh no never mind that man they got my
daddy's watch
[ __ ] that
how dare you
rehearse it
right oh down to your socks
how we supposed to get home
i'm gonna bust your ass right you you
just forget it man
then watch a gamble to watch right if
it's that serious
let's go
say goodbye
get the hell out of here yo yo george
what's up with your
what's good with you baby what's good
with you b it was really good baby huh
what's good with you man
[Laughter]
women have families
pop knobbing funny
[Laughter]
oh god
you [ __ ]
oh god you don't know how hard that is
steve well i was losing it here
at me
i did
i defy anyone
just sit there
pop knob
men have knobs
we meet our families
a man has a knob
pop nobody
you fasted
[Music]
oh
i love you
now okay
i love you
you know all that other stuff but you
don't know his name
man
people tell me [ __ ]
what's wrong with you
man
you give up hope you hung yourself
because of this [ __ ] airplane is
coming over make me have to loop all
this [ __ ] i ain't looking [ __ ] we need
to get it now not at all
i'm a very rare blood type i'm a b
positive hmm
sounds delicious
positive iv positive okay sorry i have a
[Laughter]
i put my hands on your [ __ ] ty
yeah
okay see see now
i'm not being a martyr
i'm who the hell am i
oh yeah [ __ ] okay martyr i'm not being a
martyr i'm the victim here
don't you smile don't you smile right
now
is it the fact that i've got one like
show than either
you have noticed
what are you doing rick
it's the police dog
on a dare
it was weird after
but then it was okay
dog died later oh my god
aids
sorry
[Music]
i'm real sorry
[Music]
she's going away a long long time